seen you off the Academy Awards on that
red carpet it was truly a moment I mean
what how would you sum up this whole
experience for you so far well this
entire award season this year has been
non-stop and amazing it's like a dream
come true you know from Paris Texas and
the beat like out here in Hollywood and
red carpets and Lady Gaga GLAAD Awards
and it's just phenomenal I mean when you
first did drag race the first time could
you ever anticipate all of this would
happen under the first of many times
okay yes you know what I always knew
that I was very thankful and I want to
go out there and make the most of any
opportunity that I had and doing the
work has led me to this moment today so
I'm so thrilled it is mother monster's
birthday today did you text her honey I
don't have the direct sale but I got
away by the way by the way kind of way
so I've definitely post on Instagram I
tagged her and I sent her some love for
sure I love her and Connie halle-loo so
what's up next for you I'm sure you're
busy well you know last year I just
finished a 184 city tour around the
world so this year I was like let's get
back to LA let's focus on being here
working and more television and film and
so being a part of this and being able
to experience all this it's phenomenal
tonight and also to be on ariana grande
travel come on now I'm track three on a
couple of album Nessebar is born album
I'm French dialogue that's me and on
Ariana's new album whoo I just went to
her opening night of the tour with my
friend Frankie at her brother and it was
phenomenal like anybody who should see
it tour to see the sweetener tour it's
so good I mean how does that all go down
how did you get on the track well I was
in the studio with her because Frankie
and I just stopped by there and she was
like playing some tracks from the new
album I was thrilled listen Jeff of
course you got a sneak peek of the
ariana grande animal yeah and after I
heard NASA I was like oh I love it and I
can't wait cuz in my version she was
like your version I was like you know
the drag bears a girl I want to come out
and say you know this is one small step
for woman one giant leap for womankind
and she was like oh my god you need to
say that right now my phone
oh one shot this year has been just so
groundbreaking for me personally first
Queen to be able to go to the Oscars and
walk the red carpet you know the first
drag queen to be on an album with ariana
grande and to also be a part of a movie
like a star is born it's so great you
know what's next what trying to collab
with Beyonce cuz she's here tonight oh
don't think I don't know okay I've
already got a game plan and how can get
close now I'm not gonna get that close
because I saw security I'll take you
down his name is Julius to Beyonce and
jay-z but I'm you know what it's amazing
for me to be in the room this night my
first drag number that I ever did was
Beyonce single ladies in 2009 and fast
forward 10 years and here I am in a room
where she's gonna be honored and I'm
also cost in the live auction tonight
and you know it's just phenomenal
honey I'm putting a ring on it you're on
top of the world let's do one of these
come on
[Music]